welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this episode
we're going to be ranking all of the Fox
x-men movies from worst to best we'll be
covering all of the films in the
franchise as well as the most recently
released one at Dark Phoenix and with
that set to end the film franchise this
is our definitive list make sure you
leave your list in the comments below
and don't forget to subscribe to the
channel for daily videos like this
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this I hope
you enjoy it now sit back relax and
let's get into my list of the x-men
films ranked from worst to best number
12
x-men origins Wolverine x-men origins
Wolverine pretty much ensured that none
of the other characters were getting
solo movies after a completely ruined
Wolverine this is a key example of why
prequels don't really work and the
plodding film has pretty much become the
laughing joke of the franchise this
messed it all up
Sabretooth gambit and Deadpool to the
point that Ryan Reynolds had to go back
in time and kill this version of the
character in Deadpool twos paws credits
scene this is a disaster and whether
it's bad CGI walking away from
explosions or will.i.am being in the
film this is bad bad bad number 11 x-men
The Last Stand x-men The Last Stand had
so much potential but it completely
dropped the ball this is the first film
in the franchise to tackle the Dark
Phoenix saga and it does so prey
disastrously with a lot of the drama
that should come from it becoming pure
schlock Vinnie Jones casting as the
juggernaut is laughably bad rogue is
relegated to a d-lister Halle Berry gets
far more screen time than she deserves
Cyclops is pretty much thrown out in the
first five minutes and Professor X gets
a laughable death that is so bad that
the rest of the franchise completely
ignored it upon resurrecting him there
are some excellent moments in the films
such as magneto playing chess at the end
and missing Charles but overall is just
so much bad here that it leaves
sour taste this pretty much destroyed
the original cast being put in the
movies for several years and due to that
it ranks very low on the list number 10
x-men at Dark Phoenix x-men Dark Phoenix
is our latest and last entry in the
franchise at this point the Dark Phoenix
saga seems impossible to adapt and this
feels like another failed attempt it's
not bad it's not amazing it's just very
middle-of-the-road and feels like a
completely unnecessary entry that
doesn't really do anything good or bad I
think at this point that the x-men
franchise has run its course and whilst
we've had some amazing films this feels
like the right time to put an end to it
and pass it over to Disney number 9
x-men apocalypse x-men apocalypse is a
film and quite torn on though I enjoyed
it quite a lot upon first watch after
repeat viewings of the film it just
doesn't quite hold up the new team don't
possess the charisma of the original or
even first class group and the movie
drags in quite a lot of sections making
for a difficult second watch especially
due to its lengthy runtime in comparison
to Thanos apocalypse really falls flat
no Oscar Isaacs does well with what
material he's given all in all he
doesn't feel quite as terrifying as he
should there are still some stunning
visuals here but nothing feels like a
real high point of the series and that's
why I ranks lower in the list number 8
x2 now the position of this film is
something that I kind of went back and
forth on because whilst I loved it I
actually prefer the first film and it's
just too much Kitty fight stuff in this
and I feel like the movie there's a lot
of jokes that don't really land Cyclops
is relegated to a side character here
Halle Berry again gets far too much
screen time and Lady Deathstrike is
handled abysmally so those are my
reasons why it doesn't rank higher now
saying all that it's still a really
enjoyable Brian Cox makes a phenomenal
villain as William Stryker and he's
arguably one of the best in the series
The Wolverine arc 2 really develops here
and again added sense of the mutant
legislation pressure after the
phenomenal Nightcrawler intro overall
it's still an excellent film
just drops the ball a bit for me in
certain areas that makes it rank
slightly lower for me that I'm sure it
will for most number seven x-men first
class x-men first class is a real shot
in the arm for the franchise that
reintroduces the central x-men
characters in a fantastic new way The
Incredible bond-esque first half-hour
that follows magneto as he tracks down
the Nazis that murdered his family
coupled with the enthralling origin
story for Professor X and mystique are
wonderfully portrayed and this period
piece feels like a fresh new start that
revitalizes the franchise in many
interesting ways number 6
Deadpool there are four or five moments
in your life four or five moments where
you get to see a film this
groundbreaking Deadpool was and still is
a complete game-changer in the superhero
genre after taking years to finally come
to fruition nothing about this film
falls flat with the movie's
revolutionising the r-rated comic book
film and creating a massive trendsetter
Deadpool is unique in its fourth wall
breaking dialogue that makes every
moment shine throughout the film the
movie is hilarious from start to finish
and it also has a heart that really
elevates it above the majority of movies
on this list brilliant from beginning to
end
Deadpool deserves its high ranking
number 5 Deadpool 2 the extended cut
Deadpool 2 for me bettered its
predecessor in every way whether it's
the dialogue comedy action or characters
every aspect of the film feels like a
step up and it's a brilliant movie that
has improved even more by its extended
cut that adds more profanity and goal
whether it's the hilarious cameos
outstanding music or expanded cast
everything feels like an upgrade from
the first film and it's an amazing movie
from beginning to end
number four x-men x-men is a film that I
fell in love with upon first viewing and
even today I regard it really highly
this kick-started the comic book movie
craze and feels like a blast from start
to finish every character is perfectly
introduced and it's incredible what the
creative team were able to pull off
first goal when films like Justice
League still fail did you go characters
in this
the movie made a star of Hugh Jackman
and rightly so he's incredible in the
role and when you have phenomenal actors
like Patrick Stewart Ian McKellen and
more backing them up it's difficult to
go wrong this is the original and still
one of the best and that's why it ranks
so highly on our list number three the
Wolverine to me the Wolverine feels like
the quintessential solo outing for the
character that is as close to the comics
as humanly possible in the Fox universe
from the Incredible atom bomb opening
all the way to the bone claws at the end
this film feels and thrilling unique and
emotional the extended cut features far
more violence and gore than the
theatrical version and expertly
showcases why Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
is one of the best comic book characters
ever put to screen it's amazing that
this movie was filmed in Australia as
the set design makes it look completely
authentic as a japanese locale and it
makes me wish that more films use the
country as a setting overall this is a
brilliant piece that definitely deserves
a revisit if you're a bit soso on it as
the action acting and in-depth look at
Logan's psychology is phenomenal number
two Logan
coming in at a close second is Logan
though it could be argued that on any
given day this is the best film in the
franchise
Logan transcends the genre and works
just as well as a drama piece as it does
a comic movie every actor is giving
their all in the film and whilst it has
a far slower pace than the other movies
in the franchise it heightens the drama
through impactful moments and
heartbreaking story beats Logan is a
near-perfect film that is probably one
of the best comic book movies ever made
and it just slightly just slightly loses
out to number one number one x-men Days
of Future past at the roll cut x-men
Days of Future past is the pinnacle of
the x-men franchise for me set in an
apocalyptic future the film immediately
sets up the threat of the Sentinels in
one of the most devastating
introductions in the entire series and
here it's breakneck pace solid acting
passing of the torch from the old
generation to the new and the rest
massively elevates it this time travel
story not only successfully adapts the
source material but to me it also
betters it the movie really has
everything and the film perfectly
balances the future with the 1970s
period setting in an astounding manner
this solved a lot of the problems of the
franchise and whilst it would go on to
create more this beautifully feels like
a high point oh and don't forget the
Quicksilver scene which is by far the
best action moment the entire run and
you have the greatest x-men movie ever
made and that's my list obviously I'd
love to hear yours and where you rank
the films of the franchise comment below
and let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you subscribe to the channel for my
ending explained breakdown of Dark
Phoenix which will be out in the next
couple of days this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time
take
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]